Hi!
Suddenly really self-conscious.
What was that?
This is my documentary.
Hold on.
Look.
Me.
Why the doki looks so flat?
Because I haven't gotten a pillow for it yet.
So he's flat right now.
Because I haven't gotten a pillow for him yet.
Is that tea on the left?
It is!
It's my tea!
Yippee!
I'm drinking Gamma-micha as I always do.
It's in my favorite mug even.
Look at my finger.
It's so lumpy.
Lumpy finger.
Can I have a sip?
No.
Can you give us a smooch, please?
Why?
The glove is bigger than you.
These are pretty...
Why is it so lumpy?
Like... You see this?
Look at this!
Wait.
Do I have another pair?
Hold on.
Goodbye, gloves.
Goodbye, lumpy gloves.
Oh, I will move my...
Oh, I think I forgot to tweet.
I will move my keyboard once I...
Once I am prepared.
There we go!
That's much better.
I don't know how I would do anything with those other gloves.
Wow!
Hold on also.
There we go.
Lumpy no more!
Just a little bit.
Just a little bit lumpy.
Lumpy no more!
Nice desk?
Thank you!
Welcome to my...
Streaming desk.
And such.
Hold on.
Don't look at that.
Yeah.
As you can see...
I like...
Cinnamoroll.
Small, cute.
Chuu!
My Oshii has lumpy hands.
No!
Why do you have the extra lumpy gloves?
Well, I didn't buy them with the intent of them...
Oh, I need to tweet.
With the intent of them being lumpy.
Twitter.
Haunting now.
Tweet.
Oh my gosh, you guys saw me live tweet.
Yeah, look at this.
When I tweet...
No, not when I tweet.
When I type...
It does the thing where like...
So...
It turns the color...
Of what I type.
So, look at the T.
Yeah, it's fantastic.
And then...
You guys probably can't see...
My...
Escape key.
It's not focusing.
But my escape key is Minto.
My escape key is Minto.
Focus camera, focus.
It's okay.
I'm using a different webcam today.
So, I'm not quite used to it.
Thanks for the three months of fun from a lurker.
Devanna, thank you.
It's blurry, but it's cute.
Yeah.
I got it from...
Offky.
Sorry, I don't remember the artist.
I'm so sorry.
She said...
Chu.
Anyway...
Let's put my keyboard somewhere.
Because I'm not going to be needing it.
Today.
Or...
At this moment.
Mint's lumps.
Her lovely finger lumps.
Check them out.
I drive...
I drive these...
Ghosties crazy.
I do it on the daily.
They treat me really nice.
And they buy me lots of Icy's.
Hold on.
Cheese.
I put it on a looping...
Or not a looping.
I put it on like a playlist.
Rather than...
One singular BGM.
But if it gets distracting, just let me know.
Cheese.
Hold on.
I can give myself bunny ears.
Cheese.
I'm going to die.
Cheese...
Cheese.
CHEESE!!!
Yes, and my tea.
Sh spiritual.
I remember the one time I sent my new keyboard...
And one of my keys came flying off.
That was the day I truly lost control.
Let's get a...
Let's get out of here.
Chat summary auto-generated experiment.
Quality may vary.
Vtubers are talking about the streamer's cute Minto keyboard and are excited about the possibility of a concert or single release.
Yes!
I was earlier on Doki's stream and we announced that we'll be doing...
She's at, what is it, Anirivo, I think?
And we'll be doing a concert together!
And so...
YAY!
We're doing a concert together!
She invited me!
I was like, wow, really?
Me?
Oh my god!
So...
Yeah, if you didn't watch, I was on her stream earlier and we announced that and we did some VR chat shenanigans.
I felt really bad though.
I'm sorry if I felt maybe a little low energy in it because I put on my headset and immediately...
Don't tell her, don't tell her I said this, but I immediately felt so sick.
I'm like okay so, and I kinda mentioned it on the stream too but five minutes before hand...
I was- I was spending like two hours trying to get my VR chat model to work.
Um..
And I was like, maybe even more than two hours I don't even know.
And it just wouldn't work at all and I was like freaking out and I really freaked myself out.
Until like...
And then once it all worked out, it kind of came down, but my brain hurt, and so then when I put on, and I hadn't eaten, so when I put on the headset, I was like, oh no, I think I've got to be sick, and so I felt really, so sorry if I was low energy, but I was really excited,
and I love doing stuff in VR chat, so...
VR do be discombobulating.
By the end, I was like, oh my god, I think I might pass away.
Again, this is my brain thoughts.
They're coming from my head.
Might pass away again.
But, yeah, we're gonna be doing that together.
Yeah.
Couldn't tell you were low energy?
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm like, I'm like...
85%.
Yeah.
Look at this little guy.
Isn't he so cute?
Emory got him for me.
A long time ago, actually.
She was like, it's literally you.
It's a ghost in heaven.
Look how cute.
Oh, oh wait, it's upside down.
Look how cute he is.
Got the wings and everything.
So he sits on my desk.
What else do I have on my desk?
That's exciting.
Oh, I have this, which is my Steins Gate calendar that I haven't up, it's a block calendar, but I haven't updated it.
Yeah, I haven't updated it.
So the numbers are all wrong, but I keep it here and I look at it.
And what else do I have?
Oh, I have my, my bag of yen.
Well, I recently, originally it's a blue, oh, it's a blue archive bag, but I put my yen in it because I was like, oh, now I have a coin purse.
I'll be going back soonish.
So my bag of yen, it wasn't originally on my desk, but why is it on my desk?
I have, um, my Ayami coaster.
I don't use it.
I just like to look at it.
And I have, oh, I don't know if I ever showed this before.
Actually, I'm going to take it out of the sleeve real quick.
Um, so that, uh, you can see it maybe better.
Actually, Ayami drew this for me and gave it to me at, um, Anime Central.
I don't know if I ever showed you guys before.
It's so cute though, right?
Sorry that it's not focusing very well, but it's so cute.
Push, push.
It's so cute, Ayami-sensei.
Look, she even gave me earrings.
I just noticed.
A little ghostly earring.
So cute.
Yeah.
Um, first time we've seen.
I have lots of stuff on my desk.
What else do I have on here?
I can show you guys.
Well, that's not on my desk.
I actually have that, like, kind of displayed.
Okay, you know what?
The background changing is annoying me.
I don't want to, I don't like it anymore.
Um, what one did I just have it on?
No.
I'll do this one.
Oh no!
I got rid of my...
Okay.
No figures on my desk?
No, I keep my figures in a...
In a...
Store in... in glass.
In its own place.
Display case!
I actually...
They're not figures though.
I have a lot of acrylic stands in here.
Oh my gosh, I have these?
Hold on.
I was cleaning earlier.
I have...
I have blue eyes, white dragon, cinnamorolls.
I got both of these from Ofcai actually.
Someone gifted them.
I think two different people gifted them to me.
Which they're so funny looking.
They're so cute!
Why?
Because I love blue eyes, white dragon and I love cinnamorolls!
Obviously!
Now I need a third.
I know!
I can become Seto Mintba.
Yeah...
So if anyone has one and wants to give it to me...
But these two can kiss.
Are they still coming out in the U.S.?
Oh, I don't know!
I think they were announced for the U.S.
actually.
But yeah, whoever got me these, thank you!
I have them with me.
Oh gosh.
This is just becoming like me showing off my stuff.
That's kind of fun, right?
I never get to... I think this...
Besides... besides the pachinko...
I think this is my first ever hand cam.
ViviCore, thanks for the gift!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Wait...
I think it's my first... I think it's my first...
I'm nervous.
What is this?
But today we're building a thing.
Today we're building...
I mean, I have the box right next to me as you can see.
But I will show you this box as well.
Sakura Densha.
So basically, there's like this...
I guess it's a...
A fad.
It's like a...
It's like... it's really popular now.
To get these...
Like bookshelf inserts that are very... that are like little miniature worlds.
Like a book nook.
Yeah!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
But yeah...
So...
We're going to be making this one.
The one that I got.
They had other ones too.
I don't remember what the other ones were.
But I really liked the train.
So I wanted the train.
Book diorama.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
And then all the gnomes that live in my house can all like...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
They can take the train to...
Wait, are those people in there?
Oh my god!
There's actual people!
On the train!
It says here...
Sakura Nodensha.
She got gnomes.
There's like everything in this...
maid cafe.
But yeah!
So I already unboxed it.
Here's our instructions everybody.
With Sakura fluttering in the sky...
Whisper your name...
over and over.
Wait, what?
I just read that for the first time just now.
Mento, Mento...
What?
Hmm?
Huh?
Abby!
Why?
Why so many gifted?
Makes my...
wrist look thick.
Why?
Thank you.
Thank you, thanks for the vibe!
Why?
All must become wisp.
Thank you for the vibe.
No, I'm just kidding.
David, thank you for the vibe.
Thank you!
Should be as tall as a book.
I have a book, hold on.
How tall do you think?
Like this one?
Oh, they're basically the same height.
This is the Metal Gear Solid 4.
That's why it says, Saraba Snake.
Goodbye Snake.
Farewell Snake.
And then this one's Metal Gear Solid 2, but it's in English.
This one, Nihongo.
But I also own the English version of this too.
Oh my gosh.
Alan!
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
And Woda!
Woda the hedgehog.
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Thank you so much!
Did I miss anybody?
C2, thanks for the 5!
Oh my gosh, wait, there's so many!
Jessens, thank you for the 50!
You guys, I can't just be...
Scarlet, thank you for the 5.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Yurien, thank you for the 5!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Teacup, thank you for the 5!
Thank you!
I think I got all of them.
You missed a flood.
What the hell?
Run it!
Thank you for the 20!
Okay.
So this is our instruction manual today.
Like so.
Is this...
Oshama!
Thank you for the 5!
Thank you!
Anyribo is local.
Let's go!
See you there then.
They wanted to see if I could do like a meet and greet and even two.
But I was like, I have another convention that same weekend unfortunately.
So the timing...
The timing...
Maybe one day I'll be invited as an actual guest.
So...
Hmm...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Hold
on, I'm gonna move my tea over here.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, there's too many...
Oh my god.
Mr. Obese, thank you.
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you for the 10!
Got the same book nook for another wisp about a year ago.
No way, really!
Thank you for the 5!
Oh my gosh.
You guys.
Thank you for the 10!
Oh my gosh, you guys!
You guys!
Chat is now all green.
Oh my gosh.
That doesn't stop!
It doesn't stop!
Please!
Please.
I'm trying to look for...
Hold on, I'm trying to look for my remote for my fan.
I'm just gonna turn it on right here.
I don't know where I put it.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I found it.
My little remote.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I can't even keep up.
I can't even...
YouTube is not even letting me scroll through.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Wait, where did I even leave off at?
I don't even know.
Oh my gosh, there's too many!
Nexy!
Thank you for the 50!
Gumball!
Thank you for the 10!
Flip DMT!
Thank you for the 5!
Stupid Shark!
Thank you for the 20!
Shirakuma!
Star Creator!
Thank you for the 20!
Try Princess!
Thank you for the 5!
Balthazar!
Thank you for the gifted!
Tsutana!
Capefire!
Thank you for the 5!
Oh my gosh, I'm already behind.
Albin!
Thank you for the 5!
English and Fix!
C2!
Thank you for the 10!
Beep Beep Soul!
Wrong For Robin!
Thank you for the 5!
Nyaah!
Thank you for the 20!
Emily!
Emery, look!
I showed them earlier.
I was like, this is on my desk.
This is on my desk.
Hi, Emery!
I keep it on my desk.
Burberry, Burberry, thank you for the gift.
I'm so happy he's haunting your desk.
Yeah!
Thanks for the turn!
Football, thank you for the turn!
No, thank you, thank you!
Thanks for becoming a member!
Thank you!
Thank you for the five!
I think I've got it.
Nice.
I think I forgot scissors.
Because I have all this.
Oh, it's all in plastic.
One second.
I think I have to go get scissors for it.
Look at all these pieces!
Oh, you can see my computer screen.
Let's see.
Take out some of the stuff.
There's the batteries.
I don't know what this is.
Glue, maybe?
I need scissors 61.
You guys, I forgot scissors.
Actually, I think I need to go get some scissors.
I'll be right back.
I'm back, baby.
I'm back.
Stop, stop!
I was gone for two seconds!
Empty gloves?
She's a ghost?
I know.
That's what I'm saying.
Scissors.
Let me crack this bad boy open.
I'm kind of nervous about making this.
I have to do it carefully, though.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Why?
Why do I have to wear gloves?
No.
It's so that you guys can see me.
You know?
It's my ghostliness.
But it's so hard to open anything!
I actually had no intention of doing this on stream.
I bought it for myself.
But I just kind of never did it.
I was like, I never have time to do it.
Maybe I'll just...
make it on stream, is what I said.
Just do it on stream!
Oh my god.
You guys, I'm like...
The hole is right here!
The opening is right there!
I just made it!
Come on!
Peel!
We're doing it live, baby.
There we go.
Okay.
Plastic on the floor!
It's okay.
I'm a maid.
I clean it up later.
Plastic!
Can you guys hear it?
Plaster!
Plastic!
That's not plastic.
What is this?
Actually, what is this?
Huh.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Why can't I get the rest off?
It smells like...
It smells like wood.
Oh my god.
I'm trying not to break stuff, but...
Give me something to break.
About your...
heckin' plastic.
Alright, we got...
Oh!
This is a sandpaper.
On the stuff.
This is...
Oh!
This is reflective.
Actually, no.
It's not so bad.
It's a thing.
I thought it was a mirror for a second.
I had a...
I had a little jump scare there.
We have some sakura something-somethings.
I've always wanted to do one of these.
I'm gonna go buy one.
Let's go!
Here's some more thingies.
This reminds me of when I was putting together my... I have a wooden revolver.
Wow!
Look at all the details and stuff!
Wait, this is just... this is thin actually.
Oh!
Wait, I think something just fell out.
Uh-oh.
That part just popped out of that hole.
Oh no, it's too thin!
Uh-oh.
Okay.
We're all ready.
I'll just put it right back in there.
Oh, shoot.
Um, just... What if I put it in like this?
Nice.
Perfect.
Perfection.
Look!
There's the people!
That's...
That's... Wait, can you see it?
Those are the people!
The people.
Uh-huh.
There's a cat!
Look how cute he is!
Book...
Oh, stories in books.
Stories...
in books.
Okay.
What do we name him?
We'll name him once we get there.
I think this is the outside of the book, right?
We have some wood...
Oh, this smells...
That's the wood scent.
And... Oh my gosh, there's so many pieces.
I don't think we're gonna finish this today.
Stories in books?
Some more?
And then all of these.
Sniffa.
No, this doesn't... This one doesn't...
Gloves are gonna be...
amazing with the glue?
No, the glue is...
a pen.
It's a pen.
Rest in glitch days.
Thank you for the five!
Thank you!
It'll be fine.
Until the glue...
gloves... F with the glue?
Oh, no, no, no.
We'll be fine!
Okay, let me put all of this now.
I moved my tea over there, but I'm actually gonna move it over here.
I also have these.
I don't know if I'll need them.
I have some...
some Gundam nips.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Let's read the instructions and see what we need first.
Let's go.
Stories and stories and stories and stories.
Oh!
We're fine.
My strength has no...
no bounds.
Okay.
This thing... Ruined!
Soiled it!
And then this is a battery pack.
Because it actually has lights.
So that's very cool.
I'm gonna put that over there.
I don't know what these are.
I think this... Oh, this looks like a railroad.
And then... parts.
And glue.
Soiled it!
Alrighty.
Let's open our magical book.
Our Ikea instructions.
That's the fence.
Oh.
Okay.
Equipped with two controllable lights.
Hidden battery.
Colorful world and river reflection.
Oh my gosh!
It's gonna look so good!
Touch... There's a touch light!
How many pages?
Thirty four... Thirty... Thirty three!
Thirty three pages.
Look!
They have... Okay.
Sakura Densha.
Densha.
Sunshine Town.
Magic House.
And Time Travel.
Wait!
Time Travel has like a really cool...
Train.
But I think I like Sakura Densha most.
Sunshine Town is pretty cool too.
Magic House?
Looks like you can't see enough of it.
Looks like the border blocks too much of it.
Huh.
But Time Travel looks really awesome.
Sunshine Town does too.
I like the colors in Magic House.
Wait.
Oh!
I like the window!
It looks really nice actually.
I'm a sucker for trains.
Me too!
Oh!
I'm already feeling the pressure here.
Please read Q&A in the previous page before...
Oh!
Here's where my favorite ghost mates swarm.
Thank you!
Where's the Q&A?
Oh!
What if there are burrs?
What's a burr?
On the edges of parts.
Burr.
A sliver?
A fuzzy thing?
A knot?
In order to ensure your safety and its installation accuracy, please remove the parts first.
Then use the included sandpaper to polish the edge burrs of the parts.
Okay.
So if there's any burrs...
We sand those guys out.
How to deal with loose parts after repeated disassembly.
Apply some glue on joints to fix up the parts.
What need to be considered when assembling the pet and mirror?
Remove the films of the pet and mirror before assembling.
Then apply some glue on them and press 5 to 10 seconds...
There is mirrors.
Burr is a piece sticking out.
Thank you!
The 20th!
Thank you so much!
I really really appreciate it.
What need to be considered when connecting the battery box with the light?
Twist the same color...
I'm becoming an electrician?
Twist the same color wires together.
If you connect red with black, it will short out after powering on.
The light cannot work properly.
Okay.
Same color, same color, same color.
Oh my god.
What if the light cannot work after connecting the battery box with the light?
First check if the wire connection is wrong.
Correct same color wires together.
Check if they have loaded the batteries properly and if the switch is turned on.
Turn off the battery box switch.
Then tear off the insulation tape.
Check the copper wires are broken and reconnect.
I'm gonna start a fire with this.
I think I'm gonna start a fire.
Oh god.
How to use the touch light?
After assembly, you can touch the switch on the front board lightly and all light beads will be on.
Cool!
Okay, I read the Q&A.
Why do you send me things when your name is like that?
Please.
Thank you for the 10 gifts.
Please mint phantom.
I can't read the rest.
My reading comprehension is so...
They're a real fan?
Is that what we're calling it now?
Alright.
Apply a dab of glue...
Okay, D2...
C3.
D2... Oh gosh.
I have to go through all of these to find...
What?
Oh my gosh.
I have to go through all of these to find D2.
Okay, guys.
Time to find D2.
Any Ds in here?
Oh wait.
No.
These are all numbers, I think.
These are all numbers.
D2, D2, D2...
Oh my gosh.
Everything is coming apart.
This is a mess!
Nathan, thank you for the 5 gifts.
Thank you.
Where are Ds?
Where is D?
Oh, I found A!
You guys, this is A.
This is all A.
A1 to A25.
This part is A.
And it was C3.
There are some Cs on here.
C3?
Is this one.
Doesn't look like the picture, though.
Also, which way is this one?
Is C3 facing?
It broke.
But it's not even the same shape!
Let's continue onward.
There might be another C3.
Right.
Where is D?
This...
This is F.
One job.
Shut up!
There's probably another C3.
This...
is G.
We are going through the whole alphabet, but we can't find D.
This...
This has to be it.
D!
D...
2.
Oh, it's tiny.
I feel
like a poltergeist right now.
D...
2.
Okay, remember this one is...
D8.
This is D8.
Stick those back in there.
These are all D2s.
Do I do it with every single one of them?
Oh yeah, I do.
I think.
Wait, A...
times 2.
B times 2.
Just gonna take all of them.
There we go.
This is like the most...
This is like the worst setup ever.
To be assembling this.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot.
Wait, where was...
Oh shoot.
I forgot C.
Hold on, I gotta bring back the C3.
PO.
C3 PO!
So I just take...
Huh?
I'm confused.
It apparently starts it already struggling.
No!
C3 to D2.
And then which...
But which way is it facing?
Okay, hold on.
Get out.
Get out of there.
I'm gonna sand this guy.
He's got some burrs on him.
It took me 12 hours, but I built a whole moving...
wooden...
looking...
solar system model out of a kit.
If I may offer some advice, spite helps.
Yeah!
I'm the greatest at being spiteful.
I'm a ghost after all.
It's an orrery, right?
I didn't say ovary.
You guys put that in my mouth.
Orrery.
It's a solar orrery.
Oh, wait!
Each side is the same color.
So we just kind of...
Look!
Okay, I gotta glue it.
Hold on, I'm also gonna...
Wait, it is that side.
Oh, it doesn't matter which side, I guess.
I hope.
Actually...
It should matter.
Because...
Okay.
I'm looking at the little...
There's a little...
This little bugger right there.
That guy sticking out.
That needs to be...
on the...
I'm gaming, okay?
I'm gaming!
I know what I'm doing!
Okay.
I have a backlog of model kits...
to build, but was able to...
finish a cool big old kit.
What?
Oh.
Where's my...
glue?
Here it is.
Glue?
I think I hear birds.
Okay.
Now, where should I...
put the glue on?
Apply a dab of glue on shaded areas.
Oh, the...
The rim, the rim, the rim.
Ooh.
Okay.
Wait, does this need to be cut?
Oh.
Wait.
There's a seal in there.
Oh, okay.
It comes undone.
Wait, how do I get the...
seal?
How do I...
get the seal out?
Did they give me...
a poker?
I hardly even know where...
Wait.
Where do I get the...
seal?
They didn't give me a poker!
How am I supposed to get the seal out?
Needle or a pin?
I have my sensei pin.
But I don't think it's long enough.
I have my blue archive sensei pin.
My shale pin.
Toothpick?
I don't have that either.
Thumbtack.
Oh wait, maybe if I go in from the inside with it.
I don't have gloves for this.
This is making me want to build my...
MGS Rex model kit.
Okay.
I'm gonna try.
I think it'll work.
Almost?
Go sensei!
Go!
I think it's working.
I got it!
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Yes, sensei!
Sensei!
Yes!
Alright, nice.
Building along with Yamito, but mine's...
a Lego bonsai tree set.
Oooh!
Are you guys ready to craft with Minto?
We're crafting together.
You're an indie Vtuber?
I wear them because I'm a ghost.
Not because I'm an indie Vtuber.
Otherwise you wouldn't be able to see my hands.
Because I'm a ghost.
Okay.
Alright.
What sucks is, for you guys to see, and for me to do this, it's kinda far away.
So, um...
Uh...
Um...
So, um...
I can't see very well.
Am I doing it well?
Am I putting it on nice?
I hope so.
God, my hands are kinda shaky.
Oh, I'm getting glue on my gloves.
Just like you guys predicted.
Oh gosh, I'm getting it...
You guys, I'm getting it in other places that's...
Okay.
There we go!
Perfect!
Oh, yeah!
Just mix it in.
That... Oh.
Oh, it's on the sides.
Oh, it's leaking.
It's leaking.
It's on the sides.
It's okay.
Just mix it in.
Don't see the glue on the...
Don't look at the...
I hope that dries clear.
Actually, hold on.
Sensei!
Sensei can scrape it out.
I love sensory pins!
And just wipe it on my gloves.
I'll put them in the wash later.
I'm a maid.
It's fun.
It just looks like it's leaking a little.
Like they have a problem.
Like some sort of...
Some sort of problem.
Okay!
Do I do that for all of them?
Oh, assemble two sets of parts.
Alright, we gotta do that again.
For another set.
Okay.
Sensei is leaking?
No, I think...
Maybe actually.
Okay.
Wait.
I think...
Yes!
Wait.
I'm confused.
I put it on the back here.
Hold on.
Okay, I'm confused.
So, remember how I said like...
Oh...
The notch is on the left side here.
Right there.
So I put it on the...
Left side is here as well.
But then here...
It's on...
The left side.
But it's showing...
Put the glue on the shaded area.
Huh?
But then here...
Did I mess up?
No, it's the same thing.
Wait, huh?
Is it two different ones?
Maybe it's the same thing, but...
Oh, I think I assembled two of each.
Oh!
I assembled two of this one.
And then I assembled two of this way.
We're okay.
So I need to make another one...
Where the notch is on the right.
And then I make two...
Where the notch is on the left.
Because it says here...
Assemble two of sets of parts.
And then here it says assemble two of sets...
Yes!
I was nervous for a second.
So this guy will be facing this way.
These guys will be facing that way.
Yeah.
Where's my C?
There we go.
C3...
C3... C3...
Oh my gosh, it fell in between my pants.
Okay, there we go.
C3...
C3... C3... C3... C3...
She's gaming.
So yeah.
Ghost wear pants.
Yeah.
My ghost pants.
My uh...
Ectopantoms.
Duh.
Ghost... IRL ghost gaming.
Oh yeah, you're pink!
Thank you!
Asto!
I got another gifted membership.
I can't buy myself.
Thanks guys.
Congratulations!
You won the...
The ghost...
The membu lottery.
Natara always told us you're a maid uniform.
I am.
But sometimes I have...
Pants on.
Duh.
It's like normal.
Okay.
Shoop.
Ah!
I can hear a good storm approaching.
Woo!
This isn't the first Super Chat saying so.
And won't be the last.
It just arrived.
What's that one...
You guys ever seen those um...
Those like...
They seem like auditions for something but they make no sense.
It's just like...
Honey, you got a storm coming.
And then they do something like...
With their hand...
They're like...
Honey, you got a big storm coming.
Yeah, I don't need friends.
They just disappoint me.
Okay, so this is the one we did.
And we'll do this one.
So we...
Glue this part.
Why?
I didn't even...
I barely even...
Why?
Okay, okay, okay.
We can fix this.
Oh no!
No, no, no.
No, I barely even touched it.
Sensei!
Wait,
where did I put...
Uh oh.
Where did I put Sensei?
Wait, this is bad because...
I didn't put the little cap on so it's...
It's spiky right now.
I'm not gonna sit on it.
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna get a spike up my butt, am I?
Oh gosh.
Wait.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Okay.
I gotta get it from the corners.
Which side am I working on?
I think this side.
Okay, we can do this now.
Okay.
See?
This is how much pressure I put on before.
And it exploded.
On me.
Take the glue.
Smear it.
Just eat it up.
Eat up the glue.
Okay, now we get Sensei back.
Which he dropped to the floor.
Trying to pick up with my toes.
Does anyone else do that?
They pick up stuff on the floor with their toes?
Do not eat the glue.
Oh my gosh.
That was one of my least favorite episodes of the Powerpuff Girls when I was a kid.
There was an episode where this guy ate glue.
I think he had a crush on Buttercup.
But he just like...
ate the glue?
And it made me feel so sick every time.
Oh no, it has hair on it.
It has cat hair on it.
Okay, we're good.
So now we get the corners.
Remember that episode?
I think they both ended up eating glue.
That's my Oshii.
She eats glue.
And your Oshii would eat glue too.
The horrible part about this is I actually want it to look nice.
I want this to look nice because I'm going to put it on my shelf.
I don't want it to be gross and glue.
Wait, how did I do the wrong sign?
How did they end up facing different directions?
Okay, this goes on this side.
Then...
Oh my god!
Okay, so we're gluing this side.
Hold on, I gotta sand it down a little bit.
You guys, this is going to be good.
When I built my revolver I accidentally got almost to the very end and realized it was all backwards and had to take it apart and redo it.
So you know.
It happens.
Easy squeeze.
Easy squeeze, easy squeeze.
Okay, there we go.
Easy squeeze.
Easy squeeze, easy squeeze.
I mean, but truly, who's...
You know what these...
Only the pictures make these look good, right?
Everybody else's always look like, you know, doo-doo garbage.
So, you know, it'll be character.
Mine might be just a little bit, like, you know...
Um...
A little something.
I don't know.
It's only ever the model pictures that make these look good.
You know, everybody else's also look bad too.
I think, probably.
Probably.
Not probably.
Definitely.
That's why you buy two.
It'll be unique.
Yeah!
It's gonna look like a labyrinth.
What are you talking about?
The McDonald's advertising.
Look!
Two of the same!
Two of the same.
Oh...
Oh, my fingers smell like glue.
And now this one.
We're on step two, you guys.
We're almost at step three.
How many steps are there?
There were thirty-four pages, and, um...
Or thirty-three pages.
Oh, and there's only thirty...
Only thirty-one steps!
We are so good.
Oh!
We got this.
We're already on step two... almost three.
Copium supplies have run dry globally.
Stop!
No, that's why I don't allow copium in my chat.
Because there is no copium here.
There's no copium in Ba Sing Se.
Okay?
Everything I speak is real.
Everything that I say happens.
I say Minto's gonna do it, I do it.
No copium in Ba Sing Se.
Yes.
Nice and easy.
I just gotta get around my fingers.
There we go.
Beautiful!
Don't mind the glue-covered fingers, okay, everybody?
I hope it's a non-toxic glue.
Probably is, though.
You think?
Get to wipe the glue off the sides...
and get Sensei in.
Never gonna be able to use this...
this...
pin ever again.
Tool facing this side...
Okay.
Next, we need...
B2...
B3...
B18.
What was B?
Which one was B?
I have A.
I have C.
C...
Step 2 completed!
You guys, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
I have G...
I have F...
I have...
B2, B18, BINGO!
3...
This is the really woody one.
This is a really good one.
I have D...
Did I ever...
I have...
I think this must be B.
E?
Where's B?
I have A?
Huh?
A...
D...
Uh...
Wait...
Is this actually B?
Oh, it's B?
I thought it was 3.
Wait...
Look at this.
None...
Okay, you can't see it at all.
But none of the...
Okay, so on all the Bs...
On every single one of them...
The line isn't filled in.
So it looks like...
Oh, gosh.
This is the one moment...
That would focus forever.
It looks like 3!
I'm gonna take a picture of this right now.
With my phone.
I'm taking a picture!
So that you guys believe me!
Oh, the camera looks like B.
No!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Right here, right here.
Okay.
I took a picture.
I'll post it later.
What did I need?
It looks like...
It's the lighting.
That's why.
Where did my other thing go?
Ah!
He fell!
Alright, we're good.
I need a B2.
Oh, gosh.
I'm gonna use my camera.
I can't tell!
I'm using my camera!
Oh, gosh.
Hold on.
B...
12?
Is that B1C or B10?
B32?
Oh, wait.
B132?
I can't tell!
I seriously can't tell!
Oh, wait!
B1, B2!
I need B2.
Okay, I found B2.
I found it.
I'm fighting for my afterlife over here.
And then I need B3.
Okay, I have both of those.
And now I need B18.
Okay, hold on.
Let's start with getting...
Okay, so this here is B2 and this one is B3.
Okay.
Nice.
B2.
Some of it came off.
To B2.
Or not to B2.
Okay.
And now B18?
This one.
Oh, this one.
This one right here.
It's kind of tricky because it's like...
It's...
I don't want to break it.
Oh, gosh.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of breaking it.
The eye patch?
You're right.
That's so funny.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
I'm scared.
I'm trying.
Why do
they have the tiniest piece?
Or the thinnest piece in the middle?
Why do they have the thinnest piece in the middle?
It's so hard to...
Push it out!
Tiny knife time.
I think my nips are too...
Too thick.
I can't believe I broke it.
I would never survive in Squid Game.
No!
How
to get it out?
You'd think that if I broke it, it would come out.
It would be nice to me.
I got it out.
Let me try the glue.
I do have super glue if I need it, though.
I have to go get it, though.
Okay, I'm gonna do this off-camera.
So I can be precise.
I will do it off-camera.
Okay, hold on.
It goes like...
Yeah, we can fix it.
I will put you back together.
Step 3 or step B?
Stop!
I don't think the glue is strong enough.
But we'll see.
We'll see.
28 steps to go.
Yup.
I feel like I should go get the super glue.
We could save it.
Maybe.
Okay.
Okay, I'm holding it.
Hold.
No, no, no, it came apart.
It came apart.
Hold.
I'm holding it.
How long should I hold it for?
It's a little wobbly.
Oh gosh.
It's a lot of wobbly.
But it's staying together.
I'm gonna hold it for some more.
Hold.
10 minutes?
What will we do for 10 minutes?
Let it set for a while.
Look though, it's together.
I'll let it sit by itself.
And think about what it's done wrong.
Oh, but I need to put...
Uh oh.
I need to put these pieces inside the holes.
These diagrams suck.
Okay.
Let's put this over here.
B14.
Oh, no one needs to go in here.
Oh wait.
This is the sign, I think.
You can barely read it here though.
Like...
Look at this.
If you think you can't read anything.
You can kind of see the indents of the letters and stuff.
But that's supposed to say something.
I could only read it with my camera.
Is that even 14?
Yeah, that's B14.
That's the sign.
What it did wrong was falling into your hands.
This is...
You...
This is wrong slanderous.
I love catching Mint live because it means it's way past my bedtime.
Asia.
But yeah.
You can barely read it at all.
Maybe I'll put...
I can't...
Mita...
Mita?
Mi...
Tala...
I can't read the rest.
Mita...
I can't read it.
I'm scared though.
Look at this part.
I'm gonna break that off.
Right there.
I think.
Mintara?
No.
No way.
I'm scared of these parts eventually.
When I have to get to this too.
Maybe I will use my nips.
Okay.
How do I use them?
Push?
No.
I'm scared.
No exacto knife?
No.
I don't have an exacto knife.
Oh gosh.
You mean snips?
Not nips?
No.
They're called nips.
I'm gonna have the box around here somewhere.
They're
called an entry nipper.
So I just call them my nips.
They're for Gundam.
She's not lying.
Why would I lie?
It's just easier to say nips.
Isn't it?
Gunpla nips.
Yeah.
What are you guys thinking of?
Get your heads out of the gutter.
We gotta get this off.
It'll take the 20 minutes to get it off.
That uh...
That it'll take for this to dry.
Look.
It's a little crooked it feels.
It's a little... It's okay.
Character.
Okay.
We did it.
And we have some burrs.
We've got some burrs to take care of.
Nice.
A few burrs.
Gundam naming convention strikes again.
I think it sounds normal.
Yeah!
Oh.
Uh oh.
My gloves are starting to get really sticky.
Look.
You can see them sticking together.
Maybe if you guys give me enough energy I can take them off.
I don't know yet though.
My nails are really bad looking.
So I'd be embarrassed.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't actually understand this part anyway.
These guys here.
You.
Does this feel as flimsy as before?
Energy.
Not now.
It's actually pretty okay.
It's actually pretty okay I think.
Yeah.
It's actually not so flimsy anymore.
Nice.
Yippee!
Jason!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Energy!
Thank you.
Um.
Uh.
Okay.
So I take B2?
And B3?
It's the...
Oh shoot.
Which one was B2?
And which one was B3?
Oh.
B3 is this one.
This one's B3.
And I'm gonna use my nips to cut this right here.
Nice.
B2 and B3 go... They kiss?
I think.
Oh.
I'm gonna use them to cut here.
There we go.
Okay.
They kiss?
The white side on the white side?
Or they connect?
I think they just kiss.
Actually I'm not quite sure.
I'm not sure of the...
Oh yeah.
I think they kiss.
They kiss like this.
And then this part goes into these...
holes?
Into these two different holes.
But facing down.
Like that I think?
Huh?
No.
Face this facing.
Huh?
Kiss kiss for the love...
Snippers you have are for plastic.
Yeah I know.
And you're really really a modeling knife for this sort of stuff.
No I don't.
Otherwise they would have provided one.
I'm good.
They kiss?
But what's that?
Hold on.
I need to look at this more closely.
Huh?
Okay.
This makes no sense.
What?
How is it supposed to look?
Huh?
How do you go?
Okay wait.
How do you go from sticking it into the hole like see how it's...
Okay it shows them kissing and then you stick it into the hole and then they're sideways!
They're like making a little bird house shape.
How does that make any sense?
Huh?
Did I get raided?
Thank you for the raid!
Sorry.
I'm so confused.
They kiss, go to the hole and then become sideways.
I guess I'm just going to make them side...
Oh!
I get it!
They make this... this is...
I get it.
I get...
I get it!
I'm gonna do it with my hands though.
I'm gonna do it with my hands...
I think it will be easier.
She got the hole!
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah.
I think I get it.
No I don't think.
I know.
I know I got it.
I got this.
Okay.
Like that?
And then like this.
And then, as they kiss, right?
Yeah.
Then they kiss.
Then there's two holes and then the third hole.
I'm breaking it!
It's gonna snap under my fingers.
I'm gaming?
Yeah, there's a third hole.
Okay, we're gonna do it like this.
Okay, okay.
I got this, you guys.
I believe.
Do you guys believe?
Try making the same model and failed.
I wish you better luck than me.
No, Pop!
No, no!
Don't say that!
Don't say that.
This is my first ever thing that I've ever made.
This is my first one that I've ever made, though.
This is like the...
Then
they converge.
I wish I could show you what I'm doing.
The third hole.
I got it!
I got the third hole!
I got the third hole.
Take your time and you'll be fine.
Yeah.
Now, I'm kind of confused because...
Wait.
No.
Because it doesn't look very even.
Maybe it's supposed to look like that.
Look, it kind of looks like...
Not straight.
But the holes are like that.
They're like uneven, so...
I guess this is uneven, too.
Let me fix this guy.
This was the third hole.
Right there!
Why does it look like that?
I don't know.
And then we put the sign in here.
Like so.
And it becomes like a little thing.
Oh my gosh.
My glove is stuck on the thing and it just...
Oh god.
Okay.
We're good.
I'm gonna put it in like this.
I'm gonna put it in.
Nice and gentle.
Gentle.
Maybe it's a perspective thing.
Oh, maybe.
Maybe.
Okay.
That's...
Hold on.
It didn't fit!
Okay.
Hold on.
Is it working?
I don't think so!
Might be so that it looks better once it's all together.
Okay.
You're right.
Easy.
Easy now.
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Okay.
I hope it's not because I broke it earlier.
I'm like really trying.
Did you see that...
Did you see that squeeze?
Maybe that's good enough.
There we go.
Yippee!
We have like a little sign.
That's so cute!
We have a little sign.
See?
Yay!
We did step...
4...
1!
Wouldn't this be step...
Why is all of this step 4?
Wait a second.
Oh my gosh.
All of this is step 4?
This is step 5?
This is, ah...
This is step 4?
Step 4 is two pages.
Okay, we need A24.
Wait a second.
A24...
We need A25, A18.
What one was A?
What is...
Oh, I found A.
A!
See, this one is so legible, so easy to understand.
24... 25... 18... Got
it.
I want to be a gnome.
Maybe you too can in another life be a gnome.
There we go.
And sand it down just a little bit.
Draw the rest of the owl.
What?
4 is the best number after all so it goes on forever.
True.
I can't argue with you there.
And then we also...
Thank you!
I think all the donuts are backed up.
So many gifts you won't notice this donut saying MintoQ.
I saw it!
There we go.
Roll.
Roll life.
Roll roll.
Life the power.
Alright and then 824 and 825.
Which are these two?
Okay, I have to remember which...
Okay, 24 is the dotted one.
Everybody.
24 is all spotted.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay.
Oh, it says 24 on it.
Just kidding.
Okay.
It says 24 on it.
So...
How do we do?
This...
With the...
With these little lines...
See them?
On the edge they go...
Like so.
Yes.
Never mind.
I had it though.
I had it.
I think.
One.
And the other one...
Goes like so.
So that 24 is on the inside.
What is this thing I'm creating anyway?
Is it like an AC maybe?
Two!
This one was so easy.
Oh, it's stuck on my...
I got it.
Very good.
It's all safe in the palm of my hand.
Now we do A22.
And that's gonna go on the bottom here.
A22.
This one.
Wait.
Oh gosh.
I have to make sure I get it but not A23.
Do I need A23?
No.
Oh.
I'll need A23 in a bit actually.
So we can get them both.
On the next page.
Take them out together?
The twins?
David and Eli, I shall name you.
Why is this piece so thin?
Sir Jet!
Thanks for three months.
Thank you.
On lunch?
What am I...
What are we building?
We're building a Sakura Densha.
Sakura Densha.
Did I just split it?
I might have just a little bit but it's fine.
No one will notice.
The part's terrible.
George?
George will come later.
Well how does it go?
First, mommy.
Then daddy.
Okay.
How does that part go?
Okay, this is 23 everybody.
23 right there.
First mommy in the...
First comes love, then comes marriage, then comes baby in the baby carriage.
Then comes George in the George carriage.
Okay, it's gotta be the white side facing up is what it's saying.
And it goes like this.
Okay.
Like this?
I guess.
Yeah, Solidus is the baby.
Baby brother.
Why would the A22...
The white side be up though?
Why would it be on the inside?
Why not the part that actually says A22 on the inside?
Curious.
Actually...
Maybe it is on the inside.
I'm looking at the holes.
Okay.
That would make more sense, right?
I'm looking at the holes.
I'm looking at the holes in the diagram.
Hmm.
Yeah, Solidus is the baby brother even though he became president and looks the oldest.
He's just a baby.
Oh.
First comes big boss, then comes big mama.
Am I doing this wrong?
Come on.
Fit in.
Why are these holes so tight?
Oh, I think it's because...
It's not able to go in because of the...
It's being blocked by...
No.
I am doing it wrong.
This side needs...
This side...
This little notch...
Right there...
Needs to be facing outward.
So I was doing it wrong.
Okay.
I guess the A22 does have to be on the outside.
Facing outward.
Because my hands are tiny?
I don't think that has anything to do with it.
Okay.
Oh.
See that fit...
That fit so much easier.
That fit so much more easily.
Okay.
Look at that.
We got a little...
Thing.
Yay.
Now we do A16.
Which is this bad boy.
And we...
Um...
Stick it in.
We glue it in there.
Actually.
Minto has baby hands.
You have baby brain.
Where did this come from?
Where did that little...
Dingle hopper come from?
Yeah.
Brutal.
Don't come...
Don't come in the kitchen unless you're ready to get...
Burned.
And now we stick this in here.
Look at that.
But what we're gonna do is we're gonna glue it.
Oh my gosh.
So cute.
We gotta glue it though.
We gotta glue it.
We glue all of the back.
Or all of this part.
No.
All of this part.
Yeah.
We glue all of that.
Where's my glue?
Here.
Just glue it.
Fib!
Thanks for three months.
Alright.
Glue, glue, glue.
We can't mess this part up you guys.
We can't...
We can't mess this part up.
You just put it in there.
There's no way we can mess it up.
You just stick it on and it's easy.
Easy peasy.
There's no way we can mess this up.
There's no way we can screw it up.
It came with the glue?
Yeah.
Isn't it nice?
There we go.
The blue glue looks delicious.
It's actually white.
It's not blue at all.
I can see why it looks blue.
Little AC unit.
It's so cute.
There's a little bit of glue.
Will you sense it?
Get it off.
My little tiny sensei.
Nice.
Noice.
Look how cute that is.
Now we do A23.
Which is this piece.
And we glue it on...
No, we snap it in on top.
I guess it doesn't matter which way it goes.
Hopefully.
This is the nicer side.
Oh my gosh, please.
Please.
Actually, I hope not.
I can't tell.
No.
I think either side works.
Right?
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
I got it in.
One side.
Oh my god.
It's a box.
Oh my gosh, this is so exciting.
Yeah.
Do a lot of these pieces need to be glued?
I don't think so.
It will tell you when to glue stuff.
Wait, this one has spare parts.
Wait, why didn't B18 have spare parts?
But these A11 and A9 have spare parts.
Why doesn't B18 have a spare part?
Oh, these ones are really...
Oh gosh.
This is what we're...
This part is what we're taking out.
11 and 9.
Have you heard that?
Like the whole piece cracked.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Everything is cracking but the thing that I need to come out.
Okay, we got 11.
Successfully extracted 11.
I should be a surgeon.
You would put your lives in my hands, right?
Look how well I'm doing.
I only broke one bone.
Yes, I got 9.
Let's get rid of some of these.
I would not.
Why not?
Be honest with me.
Why wouldn't you...
Why?
Um...
Why are you not trusting your life in Mito's hands?
Huh?
I'm gonna take this to your throat.
This is your throat I'm cutting through.
You don't need that.
You're done talking.
No, I needed that.
Think about when Mito is cute.
Which is always.
Which one was 9 and which one was 11?
Oh well.
Maybe it doesn't matter.
Oh, I can tell.
11 is long.
No, 9 is long.
11 is a little baby short.
How does this work?
Why are they sticking up in there?
So you take it and you go...
I'm afraid this won't fit.
I'm afraid it won't fit.
And then...
Sorry, I might have to do this one out.
The open part...
Is facing the back.
Is facing...
The back.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, it does fit.
It does fit.
Would you look at that?
It fit in so easily.
And then 11...
Goes in as well.
Gloves.
Gloves, gloves, gloves.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, 11 is a little more tricky.
Probably because he's short but stout.
There we go.
Okay.
We got it.
Why do I...
Why though?
Why is this piece longer?
I can't tell why.
But we got it.
Our little AC unit.
So cute.
Oh, okay.
E25.
There's more to this?
Why is this piece so intricate?
E25.
What was E?
E.
E?
This is B.
This is...
I.
A.
Oh my gosh.
This whole piece just came out of my hands.
This is F.
This is...
I got it.
How many of you guys have put one of these together before?
Two.
Thank you.
Thanks Kid Party.
E.
I admire your out-of-the-box thinking.
Housing prices are higher than ever and here you are building your own size house to live...
No, no.
It's for the gnomes.
What are you talking about?
It's not for me.
But I am trying to help out a poor gnome in a housing crisis.
Yes.
E25.
Oh my gosh.
There's so much on here.
Where would 25 even be?
If I were an E25, I'd be right here.
I found it.
I want to build this one and the forest one I saw.
Are you sure it's not just for the snake figure?
I'll be honest.
I didn't even consider that.
And now it's 100% for snake.
I didn't even consider this being for snake.
Oh, do you guys want to see him?
Wait, where is he?
He might be...
Elsewhere.
He might be out on a mission right now.
He might be on...
I was going to say he might be on a philanthropy mission.
But it's naked snake.
Where is he?
Snake?
Yeah, he's in his egg.
Yes.
Hold on.
I think he's in my purse.
So that he can never leave.
Okay.
How does this go?
It goes like this.
Oh, it fits in right there.
Oh, see.
I don't know if you guys can see it.
See that outline?
The little boxy outline in the top left corner?
That's where this goes into.
Wait, do I have to glue it?
Oh, I do.
I have to glue it.
Okay.
I glue it.
I glue.
Why though?
Konami needs to announce the release date.
He won't be released until we get the game.
Nice.
Please stand up straight.
Okay, whatever.
This goes in here.
And then I think we put E51.
Okay.
Just like that.
This is so intricate.
Why?
Why am I building the inside of this AC unit?
Nobody will see it.
Will they?
I'm literally about to put the back on.
I think.
E51.
This is A.
E.
For your satisfaction.
It has to be a functioning unit.
Or whatever.
What is the point?
E51 is right here.
Oh gosh.
I got it.
Okay.
Nice desk mat.
Thank you.
We still have our sign right here.
I'm gonna shave down these burrs.
Get them burrs.
This model was fun to build.
Good luck, Minto.
Thank you.
If I don't finish it.
That's okay.
I will...
I put it like this.
That's fine.
I put it like halfway finished.
Or halfway open.
That makes even...
Okay.
Just slip that in there.
I guess.
I wish I could use this side instead.
It's cleaner than this side.
This side has a little hole in it.
Oh well.
Oh.
I think
I got it.
There we go.
Did you hear that snap?
Oh my gosh.
I'm like a chiropractor.
Yippee!
Sorry.
I don't understand.
That was all step four.
Now we have a sign and an air con.
Next is step four.
Step five!
You guys, step five looks really exciting.
It's a lot of gluing.
But it's...
We're getting into the trees.
I speak for the trees.
So we need F and C.
I know which one C is.
Which one is F?
Oh I found F.
Okay.
I need F12.
Alex!
Thanks for the 10.
Thank you!
Thanks for the donut.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
F12, I think?
I need this.
Look, look, look.
We're getting into some colors, everybody.
F12.
Oh gosh.
Wait.
Okay.
Easy now.
Easy.
Easy peasy.
Easy breezy.
Beautiful.
Cover girl?
Cover girl, cover girl.
Cover girl, cover girl, cover girl.
Come on, come on.
Come on, come on, come on.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
This part?
This part's out.
Okay.
We did it.
Okay, we did it.
And this part goes with F.
And C.
Oh my gosh.
I just noticed C19.
And C20.
And C21.
Look at all those tiny little...
And C20.
And C21.
Look at all those tiny little...
All the individual...
All the...
I think they go on this.
So you can kind of see an outline of a...
I think we'll be pasting them on that.
Gluing them there.
C13.
C32.
This one.
Okay.
This is much thinner.
So it makes me even more nervous.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Nice, nice.
Just push down nice and easy.
Nice and easy.
Easy.
Gaming.
We're gaming.
Hey!
Oh my gosh.
I can't wait because this is going to add so much like depth, you know?
It's going to add so much depth to our little landscape.
Alright.
So.
C32.
Hey, excuse me.
Your time is over.
Goes like...
This.
And then...
F12 goes like this.
And then they...
Wow!
They line up!
Oh my god.
That's so exciting.
This is so exciting.
This is the most excitement I might have had in a long time.
It's not perfect.
There we go.
That's more perfect.
Do I glue it?
I think I glue it.
I think I glue them together.
La la la.
La la la la la.
When gnome reveal?
My gnomes are very private gnomes so...
Sorry.
You may never ever see one.
But if I'm late for stream usually that's because they've like messed up my setup.
You know, I'm trying to appease them so that I can be a better content creator.
And less late for stream.
You know, they're just sassy little guys.
So you're crying.
You're like, Minto's late.
It's not my fault.
Blame the gnomes.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
I think this is even.
This looks even.
This looks...
Sensei!
They are innocent.
You don't even know them!
The gnomes hate us.
They hate everybody though.
So I'm hoping with this, they'll love it.
They'll be like our little beautiful Sakura dream house.
I'm getting the glue out of the corners right now.
Nice.
The gnomes get a pass but I don't?
What?
Why do the gnomes get a pass?
But you know, before you even knew of the gnomes, you were just like...
Minto!
But why do the gnomes get a pass but Minto doesn't get a pass?
Messed up.
Alright, now we need C24.
And...
C22.
Oh, this one's a little complicated.
Okay.
C24.
This.
Get the corners.
C24.
So now we're like kind of offsetting it when we glue it.
Interesting.
Okay.
There we go.
C3.
That looks good.
C24 and C22.
This one.
Gnomes are cool.
They're just little guys.
I'm just... I'm little ghost!
I'm
little ghost!
I'm just... I'm just doing my best...
For you, Gosho-Din-sama and Josama...
To... to... to serve you and to entertain you and to...
You know, haunt you.
Gomaesama!
Thank you for the finds.
Gifted to you.
Thank you.
I think I could use a pass too.
That's all.
Need to be fair with NyanNyan maid level.
I will never be her.
Why not a second one for a little ghost?
Oh my god.
Oh!
You guys?
Oh my god!
You guys, I just broke my chair!
I just broke my chair and I don't know how.
Wait.
I just broke my chair.
This isn't my chair.
Oh god, it's really dusty.
Ew.
I just broke my chair.
I wasn't even touching it.
The gnomes did it.
The gnomes.
Chair funds.
Thank you.
What do I do?
I'll be your chair instead.
Ew.
Chair funds.
Stop!
But thank you.
Thank you for the chair funds.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Um.
Anyway, let's just continue onwards.
Okay.
So, we're taking C24.
Shoot.
Which one was 24?
Is it this one?
No.
Maybe this one?
This looks correct.
I think.
Like that?
And then, C22 goes...
Okay.
Under.
How does this work?
Huh?
Wait.
Butt cradle funds.
Stop!
Chair funds.
Snake dumpy funds.
I can't believe I just broke my chair.
Oh my gosh.
I can't put my feet down.
Oh gosh.
Hold on.
Can you help me?
Can you guys hear that?
Hold on.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to fix it.
How did she break her chair?
I don't even know!
Okay.
I can't fix it.
Oh!
It might have been a gnome attack.
Oh, man.
It's just a foot rest.
But it's not a gnome attack.
But now, the part where the foot rest went is a dangling metal thing.
And if I put my legs down, I kick it.
F chair could...
I'm saluting.
Chair!
Oh, man.
Anyway.
Okay.
I have to figure out which one is C-24 and which one is C-25.
Because I can't tell.
This is...
Wait.
They both look the...
Oh, they're the...
Are they the same?
No.
Uh-oh.
They both look really similar.
Oh, gosh.
I think this one is...
This one is C-24.
This one is C-24 and goes like this.
I don't know.
So I'm gonna glue it.
Check underneath, see if there's any bolts.
Shook loose.
I'm looking.
Oh, my God.
I almost just pulled off my entire interface.
I don't see anything.
I don't know what happened.
I seriously don't know what happened.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
You guys, I think my chair is coming undone.
I can't see anything.
I can't turn it.
Uh-oh.
You guys, I might have to end...
If I turn my chair, it makes this horrible grating.
Uh-oh.
I can't turn my...
You guys, I think I lost my chair tonight.
No way.
My chair.
I'm gonna glue this real quick.
How does it go?
Let's see.
Oh, my God.
Like...
No.
It can't go like so.
Maybe this is it.
No.
I'm confused.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't turn my chair back and forth.
It's actually...
What's wrong with it?
What happened?
Chair could...
What happened to my chair?
Oh, it's like this, I think.
Okay.
I feel like I'm doing, like, a weird puzzle.
Like so?
No.
That's too far off, I think.
I can't tell.
This part is really confusing.
Okay.
It's like this.
That's why it was so confusing.
But also, it doesn't line up.
The...
The petals don't line up.
Okay.
Do they line up here?
No.
First my chair, now my brain!
Turn it into a chair-fixing stream.
Why, chair?
Oh!
I fixed it!
I found it!
Okay.
I got it.
Not my chair.
I didn't fix my chair.
I fixed this.
Okay, hold on.
Let's just glue it on while I have it.
Let's glue it on while I have it.
So...
Oh, wait.
Move it down a little.
There we go.
Like so.
I think that's good.
Super glue the chair!
Super glue everything!
How big the forehead...
What are you talking about?
My forehead's so big.
It's just a little big, okay?
Wires for the lights I got were too short and couldn't reach all the lights?
No way!
No way, really?
Hopefully, that doesn't happen with me.
Oh, there's like a lot of glue on the other side because I'm an idiot.
But that's okay.
It's just for dimension, right?
Uh-oh.
Wait, some of these are off.
Oh, okay.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Push, push, push.
Push, push.
No, it's not already...
It's not already dried?
It can't be.
Uh-oh.
I think it's already dried.
No way.
No!
It's a little...
It's okay.
It's...
It's nature!
Nature is never perfect!
Nature is never perfect.
Now, this one goes on...
How so?
Like this?
How does this go here?
Like this.
Oh, that's so cool!
That's so neat.
I got a little bit on the tip.
That's okay.
I'm just gonna glue the corner then.
I'm too scared of doing the rest.
I'm gonna glue this.
Like so.
Okay.
Like... like so.
I think it'll stay.
I think.
I think it'll still stay.
I think it will still... oh shoot.
There.
Yeah, perfect.
Perfection, perfection.
Okay.
There we go.
Yeah!
Wow!
Our Sakura is so beautiful!
Oh my gosh.
I like this side better.
This side looks good.
Doesn't it?
Oh, there we go.
Nature is never perfect.
The rules of nature.
Thanks for the super chat.
Guys, I feel so discouraged with my chair.
I feel...
What happened?
What if... maybe... maybe it's just something weird and I...
I just... I just don't know what happened.
I don't know what happened.
When I turn...
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna take off my headphones real quick.
Oh gosh.
I'm wondering if something like got stuck?
Oh!
I'm an idiot.
I couldn't turn my chair because the metal bar that I told you that started hanging down below...
was just... was stuck on the ground.
I can turn it still.
Oh, okay.
It's just the... it's just the little...
It's just...
It's just that.
It's just this thing.
I was like, oh my gosh, why can't I turn my chair all of a sudden?
What's going on?
C...
31.
We need C31.
Oh my gosh, this is also going on the same branch.
This one right here.
C31.
Okay.
Wow, this is really full tree, isn't it?
C.
This part is like hanging on by a literal thread.
I'm like, come on.
I'll need you later.
Just hold on for a bit.
That's C1.
I need C31 and I glue it to the top of our little branch.
Duh.
Right here.
This part.
Hold.
I'm kind of confused.
I'm confused always, but you know.
Glue has shown.
It's kind of tricky though.
Like here?
I guess like that?
I guess?
I think?
I don't know.
Am I gluing it on the branch or on the back?
On the back of the...
I can't tell.
God couldn't.
Thanks for the gift.
I guess it doesn't have to be perfect.
Nature.
Nature is not perfect.
Do you guys want to see something I can do with my hands?
I can wiggle my hands.
In a cool way.
Don't...
Look at that part.
Okay, ready?
That's not the wiggle.
Watch.
Ready?
Isn't that pretty cool?
Easily distracted Oshii.
Pretty good, but can you go the other way?
So it's just this?
And this.
So if I go...
By golly, I'm doing it!
It's like patting your tummy and rubbing your head.
Doing
it!
This way is way easier.
By George!
It looks so bad!
It looks so ugly!
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Anyway.
This part's confusing.
Glue as shown.
Shown what?
I think it goes like this?
I think it goes up here.
I think.
I think so.
Or reverse.
Reverse!
No.
I think that's too high up.
I think.
I'm confused.
You should start a Discord.
There's a fan Discord, but I have no plans to start my own.
I'm sure if you were curious about the fan Discord, you could find it somewhere.
Someone will give you the link, probably.
I do not have it.
I'm not in it.
They won't let me be in it.
You know what?
I don't want to be in it either.
What if I make my own Discord?
With Blackjack and hookers.
You know what?
Forget the Discord.
I'm just gonna...
You know what?
I'm just gonna get the Blackjack.
Hold on.
I'm cutting some pieces.
Okay.
I can't tell if it's up or down.
We're all around.
I guess it kinda looks the same.
Regardless of what I do.
Okay.
I'm gonna do it.
Hold on.
I'm cutting.
I'm nipping.
It's the second time you said that reference today.
I just like that reference.
Bender's a funny guy.
It's been a long time since I watched Futurama.
Aren't there new episodes?
Futurama?
A Futurama?
Are there any good?
The newer episodes?
What is it?
I say that all the time.
I think it's one of the quotes.
Besides the take my money quote, I feel like everybody is always quoting Blackjack and hookers.
You should start a Wisp colony on an oil rig in the Pacific.
Now that's an idea!
We can call it...
W...S...F.
Wisp Sans Phantoms.
They're okay?
I think you need Disney Plus.
I don't have Disney Plus.
WSF.
It's on Hulu.
I watched... what was that other show that the creators did?
It was on Netflix, I think.
No Discord, so when next BreakStuff cover?
I don't know.
Oh, Disenchanted!
Yeah, Disenchanted.
It was okay.
I don't know if there's a new season.
If there is, I never watch it.
Yeah, the fantasy one.
Oh my gosh.
I think I need more glue on this.
I need more glue and more glue.
Okay.
Okie-dokie.
Would a Wisp Sans Phantoms mean you aren't allowed in either?
Other Phantoms... probably.
Wisps are special.
And me.
She broke her chair.
Oh yeah, Mint already broke stuff.
Give me something to break.
About my heckin' chair.
I hope you know I bought a new chair.
Trying to get the glue out from the...
That looks good, I think.
So far.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
We're going to the next page.
No way.
No way, no way, no way.
Page five!
Yeah, you're special, alright.
What do you mean by that?
I don't trust you.
I have to fix my gloves.
My gloves.
Um... F9.
F, F, F, F...
F9!
Wait, where'd this other F piece go?
Uh-oh.
Wait, we lost the biggest F...
Wait.
Wait, I lost this piece!
Uh-oh.
Wait!
Where did it go?
It's not what we need, but where is it?
It's just gone!
It's not with the rest of the Fs.
Uh-oh.
Huh?
It's literally not in the pile that I have.
But it's so huge!
You know what?
I'll save it.
That's a later Minto problem.
F9 is...
No, that's F6.
I was reading...
I read the six upside down as a nine.
Hold on.
Let's read it properly.
F9!
Okay.
Ooh.
This one's tricky.
Okay, we got this.
Oh, this one's tricky.
Okay.
Small, small.
Small, small, small.
Sm .
It's the thing that reminds me of Shoujo Rei.
Flashback, Semi no Koe.
Nina no Wakara no Kimi.
Sorry.
Come on, there we go.
Nice.
I heard a snap.
I'm the chiropractor.
Let me adjust your bones.
Yay!
F9, C17, C23.
Where did this other F piece go?
Craziness.
It's a mystery.
See?
17.
It's like the same one, just flatter.
Thinner.
There we go.
17.
And 23.
Nice.
Trying to keep this one.
Trying to keep it held on.
The goblin took it.
They're gnomes.
Get it right.
There's not goblins.
Only gnomes.
Am I gluing this?
Or...
Okay, this part is a little confusing.
F9 was this one.
Which we have this side, this white side out.
Imp.
No!
Gnomes!
You're gonna make them more angry at me.
Because you're mislabeling them.
They're gonna be more angry at me.
Oh, I'm gluing it.
Why didn't they just paint both sides instead of making me have more work for myself?
Is my question.
Why?
Why didn't they just paint both sides?
Hmm.
It's me.
I'm Shoujo Rei.
Got any other ghastly songs in the works?
I'll slowly pay my home fees to the gnome...
Oh, also I'll slowly pay my home fees to the gnome owners association.
The gnome.
That's good.
So you don't mistake the directions.
Oh.
Why do you have to be so sensible?
That seems to be...
Oh!
I pressed down and so much glue came oozing out.
I think I'm putting too much glue on this thing, you guys.
I think I'm overdoing it on the glue.
You legally cannot own a gnome.
In what country?
Tell me.
Where?
Name the law.
The section.
Everything.
And then I'll tell you I'm not from there.
Get ghosted.
No mania.
Fake.
Gotta sand this bottom part.
The law didn't stop Willy Wonka.
He's convinced he saved those guys.
Isn't he?
Actually...
Okay, so the Johnny Depp one was more accurate...
than...
the Gene Wilder one, right?
I don't...
I don't think in the Gene Wilder one they touch on how he got the gnomes.
I mean the Oompa Loompas.
But...
In Johnny Depp one, he like goes to the forest and then...
steals them?
I don't actually...
How does he acquire them?
Fan discord secured.
Thanks, Minto.
I got you!
Hehe.
Lore wise, yeah.
Gene Wilder was just happier.
Hahaha.
Johnny Depp is more in character.
Maybe that's why nobody likes it.
Because...
this character sucks.
I thought I...
I thought I had broken it.
See this piece?
Like stops...
at the end.
But this piece continues.
But it's obviously...
because it's supposed to go stuck into the ground.
Lured them with beans!
No way.
That's what he did actually?
The original author of the book actually hated the Gene Wilder version because of all the deviations.
Well, it also sounds like...
It sucked!
Hahaha.
You guys, I think I'm going to have to glue this one.
What the...
Send me your energy.
It's illegal in the country of your maid cafe.
Checkmate.
No, no, no.
Send me your energy.
And then I'll put it back on.
Because I'm shy.
Hahaha.
So...
Okay.
I'm going to do it.
But don't look.
Okay.
Don't look at my nails.
Because they look really bad.
Okay.
I'm scared.
No, I can't do this.
Hahaha.
I'm sorry.
I took your energy.
And I ate it.
Hahaha.
Thank you.
If you saw it...
No, you didn't see it.
No, you didn't.
If you saw it...
It's starting to get shaky.
I wonder if I'm hungry.
I had some pizza.
But I didn't like it.
They like...
Put too much sauce.
And I'm not really a saucy gal.
Wait, but I'm saucy mint.
Uh oh.
Hmm.
Will you trust my energy?
Hahaha.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Why?
Why shouldn't I trust you?
Ahem.
Well, if it isn't saucy mint.
Ah!
I did it.
Hahaha.
Super chat.
You're coming to Anime North.
Um.
I don't think so.
I don't know when Anime North is.
Next year?
I can only go to cons if I get invited, you guys.
And if I'm not invited, then, you know, I can't go.
So if you want me to go to a convention, you know, you could try asking them.
Be like, hey, I would really appreciate if you got the mint phantom.
Oh!
She's my favorite.
You know?
Truck con.
Yeah, but that was different.
That was...
They...
The truck people invited me.
Not the mint phantom.
Not the convention.
So...
Scandalous.
Stop.
Look.
Stop it.
I'm back to being ghostly.
Ghastly.
In fact.
If I didn't wear these, you wouldn't see nothing.
Truly.
Yay!
We have a traffic thing!
Now I need...
It says, glue along the reference lines.
Got it.
I need C11.
C11.
Which is this guy.
This little cross right here.
Tiny hands.
Tiny hands to give you tiny beat down.
Smack down.
F8.
Back to F.
There we go.
Oh!
According to plan.
You want to get beat up?
Oh!
Why am I acting like I'm surprised with that?
You cry before stream, but I know you like it.
Minto hates us.
I wish you'd hate me more.
You know?
I know you like it.
What else do we need?
F8.
C11.
C16.
Oh!
C16?
Do I need C17 also?
Just 16?
Oh!
This is all C16.
Both of these are C16.
Make us feel alive, Minto.
16.
There we go.
Wow.
This one's a lot.
C14.
This one.
And C15.
Okay.
Oh!
This one.
You've been invited to HandCon.
All you need to do is provide your fingerprint information.
Registered.
Okay.
16.
15.
Okay.
Got it.
And we're doing it...
Oh!
This one.
On this side, I believe.
Yeah.
I believe.
So this goes...
Wait, do we glue...
We glue this first, I think?
And then we glue it together, and then we put it here, and then we put these on here, and then we put...
Even though they look a little goofy, they look a little cheap.
That's okay.
Okay.
And then we put this... somewhere.
It says there's reference signs, but there's really not.
You just put it down.
Wait, does this have writing on it?
It's like... almost hiragana.
Almost.
Where did the other one go that I popped out?
Uh-oh.
A treasure mint running over me with her iPod.
I ran over you!
Oh wait, I do remember that.
I thought you meant like...
Unintentionally.
Guys.
Man overboard.
I lost a piece.
Is that on my fingers?
No.
Uh-oh.
My tummy is rumbling.
Do we have cons?
Can we give gifts at Otakuthon?
Maybe.
I might have to... I'll be honest.
I might have to start like...
So... I'm running out of space.
You guys, I can't even show you the box of stuff that I have from Off-Kai.
It's so huge.
I don't know.
It's just in the box.
I don't know where to put it.
I don't know where to put everything.
Suffering from success.
I guess so.
That's what you call that.
Let's just glue these ones down for now that I have.
Hmm.
I'm trying to like find a way to display stuff.
But I'm also like...
Where...
Where can I display it?
I might have to buy more shelving.
And more...
Maybe like display cabinet things.
Stuff like that.
No way.
I put too much glue on this?
You lie.
I put just an appropriate amount of glue on this.
Shelf building stream.
Download more shelf.
The maid cafe is only...
You know, I have to have room for tables and chairs for patrons.
Otherwise, I'll go out of business.
Funds for renting a storefront.
Explainments.
Gifts.
And merch.
Good grade.
Perfect.
You solved it.
You solved...
You did it.
You.
Reared...
Reared logarithm.
You solved the problem.
You did it.
The evil has been defeated.
I think I saw a tweet about a Hello Project idol who rents out a separate room just to store her fan letters and gifts.
No way.
New house fund?
No!
I like my maid cafe.
I like it!
I gonna do it like that.
Did someone say, funding Mint's new house?
That's all the rage right now.
Trending on Twitter.
Funding.
Oh.
Funding this ghost's new haunting location.
This is a museum.
I'd love to haunt that place.
Oh my gosh, this one is really tricky.
Maybe like that.
And then we just let it sit.
Let it... let it sit.
I think.
Here's a new house.
Oh, thank you!
Thanks for the super chat!
Alright, let's glue these guys on.
How should I glue them on?
Okay, the little...
There's like a... it's probably hard for you guys to see it, but there's a little shine direction and I want you to put it on the left.
So it looks like the light is coming from...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
No gloves mode.
No gloves mode!
Will you be at convention con this year?
You know what?
Convention con is like my go-to every year.
Love that con.
Convention con.
So yeah, you'll see me there.
I need the glue.
I'm shy.
I think I put too much glue.
Oh my gosh.
No!
My X came off!
There we go.
There we go!
Turn it around town, baby.
Oh, I sure hope this drive is clear!
There's too much glue!
Release the grippers?
No, I'm shy.
I'm shy ghost.
I can't.
It would be easier, but that's part of the challenge also.
It's with the gloves.
But also, I'm missing a thing.
There!
Oh my gosh, it looks so good!
From far away.
In the webcam.
It looks so great!
When you can't see the details.
You're just extreme, boss.
I'm extreme.
Hiya!
Um, I don't know where the other side of this went.
Oh my gosh.
What could have happened to it?
V for victory.
But no, we're missing a piece.
No victory here.
I hope I'm not like sitting on it.
I hope I didn't roll over top of it.
It's not on my dress.
I have no idea.
Where could it be?
Unless it's still...
Oh!
You guys, it was still...
It was still attached to the paper.
That's what happened.
It was still attached.
Nice.
Okay.
Then I glue it all together.
No, not to the chair.
Okay.
Or...
Okay, I have to glue it like this.
And then I glue it in the middle.
Okay, glue.
I think I might stop after this one.
Because I'm getting hungry.
Getting hungry is making me get a little shaky.
Ah...
Oh my gosh!
Too much glue!
Too...
But we're making progress.
I thought I would at least have like a base built or something.
I thought maybe that's where we would start.
I thought that they would be like, Okay, we're gonna make the build... No, I guess you have to do the inside to build around it, don't you?
I guess so.
No eating the glue.
I'm licking it from my glove.
I'm gonna have some mango.
Have some mango right here.
Hold on.
I'll show you guys.
One second.
I have to reach over.
I have some dried mango slices.
When do these expire?
It doesn't mold or anything, right?
There's only a couple pieces in here.
Yay!
Mango!
Yummy!
It only expired last month.
So it's fine.
Best buyer expired.
I don't know.
It doesn't say.
Fresh food, bud.
This is how slow I am to eat my food sometimes, though.
Tastes fine.
Yeah, and I'm already a ghost.
Who cares?
Look at that.
That's not mold.
That's how it looks.
Would you like this?
Oh, it's glue?
No, now I have mango on my fingers.
Oh, I think I ingested a little bit of glue.
That was non-toxic.
Your old mango can be resuscitated by mixing it with expired coffee jelly.
I'm still in a dream.
Glue eater.
Paste eater.
Oh, I agree.
That sounds better.
Alright, let's glue this bad boy on.
Right about... it says just... says...
Glue it centrally.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I want to sand down some of the edges first.
Glue it centrally.
Glue centrally.
And then that will lead us to...
Step 7!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll show you guys my revolver that I made too.
Before.
And...
So awesome.
Which side do I...
Okay, I think I just paste it just like around...
You know what?
I'm just gonna put a little dab on here.
Not too much.
Please, don't come spitting out.
Don't spit out!
I think it's drying on like the tip.
And so it's spitting out.
Okay.
Just a dab will do ya.
Yeah, there we go.
A little more.
There.
That's... I did too much.
Why does this happen to me?
There we go.
There we go!
Oh god, she has a gun.
Yeah!
I have a gun!
Usually nobody allows me to have a gun.
Minto...
Minto is never allowed to have a gun.
Why?
Let Minto have her gun!
Let me have my gun, please!
Oh my gosh, I cannot...
Put this down.
There we go.
There we go!
Okay.
Easy.
Push.
Yay!
Our traffic!
Danger zone!
Our danger zone stopper!
Oh wait.
I think my sign is a little crooked.
There we go.
I fixed it.
Shh!
Don't touch it.
I was just trying to push it down so it would...
You know...
Oh god, this one's not dry either.
Guys, we are in trouble.
Okay I gotta let it dry for 24 hours probably.
Is the rate of dry it needs to do.
Probably.
Okay.
Yay!
That looks more straight.
That looks better.
Okay.
We only had a few incidents today.
This breaking.
Losing that one piece.
But other than that, look at all this that we've completed as well.
Our 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
8 items.
Vivian, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh, and my chair.
Yes, I did break my chair as well.
Now we're on 7.
When do we... Oh, number 8.
We start building the train.
Oh, wait.
That's F1.
Uh-oh.
I have to find that piece.
Where does such a massive piece disappear to?
Oh, wait.
No.
That's F15.
But where did it go?
I'm at a loss.
Chocotaku!
Thank you for the 5.
Thank you.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Um...
Also, I see people donating under the donations.
I think they're all backlogged.
Pyrobug, thank you.
She can't see us all.
Mintel, cute.
I see you.
I saw you.
Space is ghost.
Thank you.
07.
07, chair-kun.
Mino, thank you.
Chair-fun, thank you.
Synapse, thank you.
Herman Minter-fun.
Hahaha.
Herman Minter-fun, thank you.
Ashes, thank you.
Actual good pizza-fun.
Let's go.
Ashes, thanks again.
Stop eating expired food.
You can't stop me.
You're not my mom.
Dry Princess, thank you.
Cool.
Today was quite a day for me.
Since I set all this up.
I had to set up the streaming setup.
And I did VR.
And I had to set all that up.
And I had to set up my model.
I forgot to do some stuff today.
See you, Blubber.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Really thanks.
Hope we have a chance to build Rex or some Gunpla someday.
Well, actually... hold on.
I have a question.
For anyone who has done Garage Kits before...
Uh-oh.
My chair is acting up again.
Ugh.
I got a Garage Kit at WanFest.
Of a Yume Minamu.
And it was quite expensive, so I don't want to mess it up.
Like, look at that.
One thousand... or...
Eighteen...
Ten...
One eight thousand.
You did great today.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Is it resin or plastic?
I think it's pla...
Dick.
Yume Minamu.
Look, it comes with some decals.
Oops, sorry, my bad.
They're very cute.
And then also...
She.
Is it the braids?
The braids?
The who?
Do you need to paint it too?
Yes.
Do you paint before you put it together or after you put it?
I think before, right?
Would be how you do it.
Look!
Oh my gosh, even the stand needs to be sanded down.
I just noticed.
Me.
I've never worked with a garage kit ever before in my afterlife.
Also me.
Let's buy a really complicated...
I don't think it's so complicated.
I wish I could show you what she's...
Oh, hold on.
I can show you...
It's not colored in the picture but...
She's very cute.
Cute.
It could be more complicated.
Oh, sorry.
It could be more complicated, I think.
But...
That's the design.
It's the Vocaloid Yume Minamu.
I know some people take commissions but I don't know any specifically for garage kits.
I have thought about asking if I should...
Seeing if I should...
Hire somebody.
Or at least...
Someone who can mentor me through it.
I'm especially concerned about the decals because...
I don't want to mess them up.
You only get one set, you know?
You need glue and putty.
Yeah.
Mentor.
Painting this would be tough.
You think so?
But it's like one step at a time, right?
And the colors are pretty basic.
I don't think there's like any gradients or...
Anything like that from what I can remember.
It's like all bunch of solid colors, so...
Hmm...
But I'm also concerned that...
Some of these pieces need to be...
Filed, sanded and stuff.
Hmm...
Hmmmm...
Maybe I should have...
Maybe I should...
Hire somebody.
I think I should hire someone...
Some of these pieces...
Are like kind of...
It's really satisfying to listen to though.
Hold on...
Okay, I probably shouldn't rub these all together because I don't want them...
To like...
Break apart in there.
Hahaha!
hahaha!
I don't want to break them apart in there.
Okay.
Yeah, I got it at WandFest.
See?
Wonder...
WonderFestival... Oh, you can't read it at all.
Gosh, this webcam!
Oh well.
So yeah, I have that.
That I've been like, wanting to...
Wanting to put together.
There's another WandFest at the end of this month.
There's a WandFest... I feel like there's more WandFest's than...
Than...
Like Comikets and stuff.
But...
What was I gonna say?
Oh!
There!
At the WandFest though...
Actually, it was so crazy.
I was just wandering around.
I was just looking around.
And stuff.
And...
Going to one area.
Where they had...
Like the more industry places.
Industry booths and stuff.
And the singer for...
Cruel Angel's Thesis was just performing.
I got to hear the singer, the original singer of Cruel Angel's Thesis was Takahashi Yoko?
Sing Cruel Angel's Thesis.
Just randomly.
Crazy.
That was so crazy.
I just walked up.
I was like, what's going on you?
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Takahashi Yoko.
Okay, I was right.
I thought my weeb card was about to be revoked there.
I thought I was about to have to get my weeb card revoked for getting the name incorrectly.
Yeah.
Ugh.
To answer some messages from earlier.
Oh, these are not made...
Oh, were other people confused?
Oh yeah, so a garage kit is basically like what Yoshi is saying.
Like...
They're...
They're fan made.
So they're very...
They can be very rough around the edges.
And...
They are...
Like...
Not...
They're not painted usually.
They're not assembled usually.
Like you have to do everything yourself.
So, it's a little...
Like a DIY stuff, you know.
Indie figures.
Exactly!
That's what it is though.
Yeah.
And...
But you can find them like so...
Like there was one blue archive one I almost got.
Cause I thought that they were pre-painted but just needed to be assembled.
But it wasn't.
It was like a Rona and Plata and swimsuits and they were...
They were so cute!
Ah!
But yeah...
You know...
I never... That was the...
That's actually the first garage kit I've ever bought.
Because I...
I don't do painting.
So I was just like...
I saw one of those.
Yeah!
I saw two of them!
There was one that I was just like...
Cute until...
When you need to assemble and paint.
I know!
And they make it look so good in the pictures!
I think I will hire somebody though.
Somewhere.
Somehow.
Wherever I can find somebody who does garage kit painting.
I don't know if I...
Like you know... I could probably find...
I mean not probably but I could find somebody who does like miniature paintings and things like that.
But I think it's a little...
Different.
So...
Hmm...
A lot of prep required?
I built garage kits before.
Oh yeah!
And I don't have an airbrush!
Which I feel would be...
Um...
It will lower the quality I feel, you know?
It's a damn fine figure.
Why the hell does mine look like that?
I know!
I would be like...
No!
I would be like... No!
Mine turned out so ugly!
And I got it!
And it was so expensive!
And I love this character so I wanted to look good!
But yeah...
You and Matara need to paint Warhammer minis.
Oh yeah...
I know!
When we were recording the Warhammer episode for the Patreon which comes out this coming Monday...
Um...
Uh... I was like...
They're tiny!
They're teeny teeny tiny!
But I've watched painting videos before.
Like how you do the... Like why I say it's kind of different I feel like to the garage kit I have is because like to do the shadows and stuff you can like paint the black and then paint over it and it kind of like does that layering effect and stuff like that.
But um...
I recently finished B.A.'s final episode.
With Shiroko it's so emo-y.
Hmm...
But yeah...
You can use inks for that too.
Oh really?
They're pretty different from garage kit painting.
Yeah...
Cole you probably... wait...
You make figures!
Have you ever done garage kit painting?
You had to paint the figures you've made right?
So...
Oh...
Aru steals the show in the anime?
Well that's because also... I mean yeah she's so cute.
But uh...
They um...
Focused on...
On them.
What's their um...
Problem solvers 68?
67?
66?
65?
As a painter of tabletop minis it's rough but sometimes it's rewarding.
Yeah...
I can imagine with the mini is it's like so much patience.
But also probably with those you would assemble them first right?
Because I feel like the parts are too many to paint before you assemble it.
They were like this big!
69?
Depends on the mini.
Sometimes you paint before assembly.
So much patience.
Too much patience.
My tea has gone cold.
So sad.
No!
It's been a few hours.
Wait how long have I been streaming for?
3 hours!
I'm tired.
Is it okay if I go to sleep?
Well not sleep.
I have some stuff I need to work on.
That I didn't get to work on today.
Because I was too busy setting up for this stream.
And setting up for this stream earlier.
I gotta respond.
I have a whole list of things of me being like reply to this email.
Reply to this email.
I gotta send my address.
They're gonna ship me a sample of my product!
Yippee!
Next week is my...
You guys next week is my anniversary.
Next week...
I'm finally able to celebrate...
My first year anniversary.
I graduated...
I graduated before I...
Before I got to celebrate.
And now...
I get to celebrate my...
First year anniversary.
Even though it's...
My four year anniversary.
First year...
I think because it's my first time celebrating.
Maybe I can say it's my first year anniversary.
I'll be honest.
I don't have so much planned.
Because...
I...
I don't have so much planned.
But...
Um...
Mint 1.0 debut...
Watch along...
Oh my gosh.
That would be wild.
I feel like usually...
For like...
Say you debuted and then you watch your...
One year...
Your debut at your one year anniversary.
I feel like I remember it.
You know?
And this...
I didn't have a proper debut actually.
I had a video that I put up.
And then I had like a stream where I answered some questions.
But even in the stream I didn't like...
Do a powerpoint or anything like that.
So...
Um...
But yeah I will have some announcements.
Of stuff.
Um...
But probably nothing that...
I don't know if pre-orders will be up.
For the things.
Pre-orders will probably be up more towards...
August.
And then I hope you'll be patient with me.
Um...
For...
Shipping stuff as well.
Um...
But...
Yeah!
I have some stuff.
MSN!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh!
In the Mei Cafe.
Straight up kissing it.
Wait that's old.
Hahaha.
That's old.
By it haha.
Well let's just say...
My Sakura Densha.
Shut up Ducky.
Hahaha.
Also I saw that spank.
It says she's not looking at these.
So cute.
Nah I do look at the donuts.
That was two hours ago.
You're right.
It was two hours ago.
It was relevant at the time.
I still would have told you to shut up.
Hahaha.
Um...
But yeah I have some fun stuff to announce.
Thank you!
Kiss!
I feel like I'll have more things to announce.
Maybe more towards my birthday.
But that's a while from now.
The gifted memberships lag it so much.
I know right?
I wish there was a way to turn it off.
Well not turn off like...
Turn off the notif from clogging it up.
Luckily I found a way so that it's not just...
Notif after notif after notif after notif after notif.
But um...
October?
I think will be...
My month.
It is my month because I'm a ghost.
Anyway, it's a spooky month.
I started fostering a cat today!
Any tips?
Wait is your first cat ever?
If you're fostering it, are you fostering to adopt?
Are you fostering so that they get adopted by someone else?
I don't think I could ever foster to get adopted by someone else.
Because I'd love the cat too much!
Yeah...
So if you guys just...
Be...
A little patient with me until...
Like October.
Which I know is quite far away.
We're mid...
We're coming up on the end of July already.
Which is crazy.
But August, September...
Two months.
And then October will be my month.
Yeah, I think.
I hope.
I hope so.
I'm praying.
Yeah.
So that's stuff.
That's just some general stuff coming up.
In the work.
In the workshops.
Praising.
Of course Minto.
I just dropped that.
That's gone forever.
No!
What else am I supposed to fiddle with?
My scissors.
So...
Yeah.
Don't play with scissors.
Don't play with scissors children!
Um...
Yeah.
I don't think...
Sorry.
I was like...
I don't think I have any other updates.
Announcement stuff.
I didn't realize that this...
I didn't mean for this to turn into an announcement thing.
Scissors ASMR.
Minto hands.
Aren't he a ghost?
I just got here.
That's why I have the gloves on.
Otherwise...
I'm...
Watch, watch.
It'll go through it.
It goes through my hand.
You see?
New announcement.
Minto cute.
You say that again.
That wasn't a threat.
It was a promise.
Just goes straight through my hand.
See?
It goes straight through my hand.
Threatening.
Threatening with flowery scissors.
Shut up.
You know who I am, boop.
I do know actually.
How is Sensei doing?
Covered in glue?
Sensei is all...
Sealed up.
I hope there's no glue.
If so, I'm gonna have to lick it off probably.
No, I think I got all of it.
I think we're good.
Sealed away forever.
Anyways, guys.
I'm gonna head out.
You have a wonderful rest of your night.
I think I probably will work more on this off stream.
I don't know if I will stream the rest to be honest.
But if I do intend on streaming it, I'll get some more done.
If I don't intend on streaming it, I'll get as much as I can done.
I'll finish it and I'll take a picture for you guys.
Obviously.
Oh, my revolver!
Yeah, hold on.
Let me show you my revolver.
So this is my revolver that I made.
And it came with these cute little people that I can shoot.
Oh wait, I don't know where the rubber bands are.
But um...
Isn't it so awesome?
Akiba Man Wars is getting freaky with this mod.
Yeah.
Look how beautiful.
It's the most beautiful weapon ever created.
I had to like put all these individuals together.
And then like get it in there with the spinny wheel and everything.
You're pretty good.
Six shots.
Enough to kill anything that moves.
I've got six shots.
I'm so organized.
Look at this.
Feeling lucky.
Oh my gosh, are we gonna play Russian or what?
So you like take the rubber band and put it like this.
And like that.
I think.
No you don't.
I just shot it backwards.
Hold on.
You take the rubber band and you put it like this.
Yes.
I think.
Put it like that.
Like on the front.
To here.
You can see it.
It went so fast.
You couldn't even see it fly.
Real gun.
Yeah.
So I keep this on my little shelf.
With all my other Metal Gear stuff.
And then...
Oh it's fun to shoot the people.
Hold on.
Don't take that out of context.
It's fun to shoot the wooden people.
Would you ever consider collecting airsoft?
Yes actually.
I've looked into it.
I've gone to like airsoft stores in Japan.
But I'm afraid of bringing them back.
I haven't gone to an airsoft store in Japan.
I haven't been in the United States yet.
Watch this.
Ready?
Aim!
Ready.
Steady.
Friend.
Fish.
Fah!
Oh.
Hahahaha.
Ready.
Steady.
Hahahaha.
Friend.
Oh.
Wait.
Confuse your enemy.
You must first confuse yourself.
Those engravings on your revolver.
No.
They're not.
It's just.
It's not engravings.
Thank you.
You're pretty good.
I have to work now.
Can I have a bit of a hand wiggle for the road?
Here you go.
Sorry I saw this late.
David.
No tactical advantage.
Okay.
Bye everybody.
Thank you for hanging out with me today.
That's so much fun.
Here's your um.
Your dose of.
If you're eating something.
If you're drinking something.
Here you go.
Some moe magic that I can.
Spread to you.
Chu.
Here's some moe moe magic.
Get out of the way.
Little person.
Oishiku nare.
Moe.
Oh.
Sorry.
Moe.
Cute.
Now your food is delicious and.
Moe-tastic.
Who was that?
Gosu.
Thanks for.
The vibe gifted.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me.
Have a great day or night.
Or whatever time it is for you.
And I will see you guys.
Tomorrow I'm playing Metal Gear Solid 2.
And.
Yeah.
Otsuminto.
Oh.
Actually hold on.
Before we go.
Special occasion.
Um.
Uh.
One sec.
There we go.
Woah.
Da da da da da da da.
Da da da da da da da da.
Beep.
Da da da da.
Beep beep.
If there's something strange.
Sleeping in your bed.
Brr brr.
Let me tell you something.
If there's something weird.
Sleeping in your bed.
Ow.
Let me tell you something.
Bustin makes me feel good.
Brr brr brr brr.
Bustin.
If
you're seeing things.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, an invisible man, sleeping in your bed.
Oh!
Let me tell you something.
Many things without five guesses.
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting makes me feel good.
Feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
Let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
Thank you for the gift.
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
An invisible bed.
Freaky ghost bed.
I'm not afraid of no bed.
Sleepy, you are sleeping.
The bed is not just a bed.
But it's a bed that makes you feel good.
Sleepy.
Please come to the bed.
Ash is gone!
Thank you for the five!
Good day!
Bye!
Feel good!
See you guys later!
Bye bye!
Thank you!